um your new album uh how many records is
it 14 14. uh obviously the cordae record
in fabulous record is dope I got to
actually pop in on the video shoot for
that you shot at Super Bowl yeah Super
Bowl weekend in AZ yeah man you were you
were I look at you like
the pivotal moment for me even shooting
a video shooting the the Curious video
bro what do you mean like JD told me
that you had booked Fab for the weekend
oh yeah yeah for the club for your club
and I saw a window of being able to be
in the same place at the same time
um we had a show in AZ as well around
the same time yeah it was a it was the
same weekend yeah yeah so it was like yo
let's make it happen corday can we get
him there
he was down we flew him in town but it
was started because
you and you guys shout out to y'all for
putting my club in the video I love that
I guess we was like yo the club scenes
are definitely from 11 11 in Scottsdale
yes sir it makes everybody's Mason
tonight yes it's good times man for you
like um how because when you're in album
mode and you're because you're obviously
we talked about that we did a radio
interview in San Diego but we got to
kind of reflect on how many bodies of
work you have at this point how many is
it now
it's like 38 it's like closing all 40 if
you include like mixtapes and stuff like
on the on the albums on just on iTunes I
have like 28 or something like that but
there's so many that I couldn't put on
iTunes so like Spotify yeah
dude damn when did you first like really
dive into
the full-time artist crime yeah
um when I dropped goat okay 2017-2018.
that doesn't feel like very long ago I
feel like you've been on like no cause
I've been dropping I would say like
2010. okay okay 2010 is when I put my
very first mixtape out
um 1010 and I think it just was a grind
of me dropping projects just out of I
create so many that I'm dropping not
knowing that they would eventually
amount to streams that pay monthly
royalty you know I mean it was just like
I'm dropping you know I'm independent
damn I should be signed to a major oh I
should be signed to a major little do I
know that me owning my masters would
give me a bigger piece of the pie at the
end of the day yeah because I can only
assume
when you have 28 projects out it's like
kind of like residual income just
hitting that account every month that's
it that's all it is once I started
piling up I was like
oh why do we need it like what is that
for again it's it's really if you need
the uh really the label is if you need
The Upfront nut at that time yeah
you know what it is it's like yeah so
you don't you don't use your own money
you don't want to invest your own time
and that's fine and also like some
artists like you know I think a major
label system probably better suits some
artists so I can play as your guys you
know yeah yeah yeah guys who kind of
lazier guys you know it just is what
like if you're going to be independent
it's the work is it's strenuous it's a
lot you got to wear multiple hats for
sure you know you got to be willing to
take a no and you know flip it and be on
for you like uh talk to me about just
like the the day-to-day stuff that you
handle being independent obviously
you're with Empire who's doing
distribution who helps the label
services but like what are you handling
yeah as EB Yeah man so I'm tapping to
the storyline of the album so you got
the writing creative in the studio then
you got the mixing process then it's
time to think of what the artwork's
gonna be the colors the aesthetic now
you got single artwork every single
attached and coinciding with the
previous to remind people that this is
all for one body of work now you got a
photo shoot that is intentional to take
people back to a time so I'm bringing
out the leather I'm leather head right
Toe with the R B Energy now we gotta
talk about music videos and I'm on the
line with the directors I'm planning I'm
picking I'm casting I'm looking for the
for the ladies I'm talking to emails
shout out to emails Diddy always came
through we shot four videos with my guy
and brought nothing but beautiful ladies
to go crazy in the videos with us man
The Styling of the videos now you got
the marketing so you're putting your
fingerprints on everything yeah I'm not
I'm not there's nothing that I don't
know that's happening that's amazing